[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kendall Square is simply
the densest collection
of life scientists in
the known universe.
It's that culture of faculty
entrepreneurs, that's what
really drove Kendall Square.
There was a lot of courage.
People really were willing to
follow the science, take risks.
I thought one day,
people will be
able to work on cancer
at the molecular level.
This was new technology
at a world historic level.
Man had the ability to make
a biological organism that
may not have ever
appeared before
in the biological kingdom.
This country, this
community, has not
decided that we should go
ahead with this research.
You've got to see it in the
shadow of the atomic bomb.
[BOOM]
They kept worrying that there
was an atomic bomb hidden away
in modern biology.
The mayor of Cambridge
became quite alarmed.
Visions of cloned
creatures infecting us.
If worst comes to
worst, we could have
a major disaster on our hands!
It was a real wild west moment.
It was really the
birth of an industry.
30, 40 years ago,
scientists tended
not to think about the
commercial aspects of what
they were doing.
Today, everyone does.
When I have an idea
for a new company,
I can go across the hall, and
I can say, has this been tried?
Do you know an
investor I can talk to?
Will you be on my board?
All of medicine is
getting rethought
in terms of the fundamental
causes of disease.
Things that were death
sentences aren't any more.
That kind of revolution doesn't
occur very often in history.
To have had the opportunity
to live through all of that
is a wonder.
[MUSIC PLAYING]